herr präsident sehr geehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen die über zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer es ist ja verlockend im
wahlkampf jetzt drei wochen vor der
bundestagswahl zu versprechen keine
sorge es wird alles so bleiben wie
bisher
aber die menschen in unserem land wissen
doch dass wir nur das erhalten können
was uns lieb und teuer ist wenn wir
endlich veränderung angehen wenn wir uns
endlich den grossen herausforderung
unserer zeit aktiv stellen und nicht
weiter abwarten diese bundestagswahl
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben das sehr
treffend gesagt ist eine richtungswahl
diese bundestagswahl ist eine
richtungswahl weil sich entscheidet ob
die nächste bundesregierung noch aktiv
einfluss auf die klimakrise nehmen kann
oder nicht und deswegen muss die frage
klimaschutz im mittelpunkt der nächsten
bundesregierung stehen
und ich finde das nicht nur befremdlich
sondern ich finde das wirklich auch mit
blick auf all die menschen in unserem
land gerade um ein arzt und eine der
ganz großen übertreibungen der grünen
ist ganz kurzen viel versprechen sie
sagen macht ihr können noch einfluss
nehmen auf die klimakrise die wahrheit
ist wir wissen es nicht wir wissen nicht
ob das was wir eine politik machen was
für unsere wirtschaft durchaus nachteile
hat noch tatsächlich einfluss haben wird
auf das was wir als globale erfahrung
betrachten das muss man einmal ganz klar
sagen wenn wir jetzt etwas tun dass
unsere wirtschaft schade wissen wir
nicht ob das überhaupt noch erfolg haben
kann
bereitgestellt aber diese 30 milliarden
euro werden doch nichts daran ändern
dass wir in zukunft bessere vorsorge
treffen wenn solche extremwetter
ereignisse wieder kommen die werden
nichts daran ändern dass wir
klimaschutzmaßnahmen betreiben oder
nicht werden wir ernst meinen dass
dieser moment einen moment war über den
wir nicht hinweggehen können bei
menschen alles verloren haben dann muss
klimaschutz im mittelpunkt der nächsten
bundesregierung stehen als klima
weil wir eine verantwortung haben
[Applaus]
die muss man einmal sagen gar nichts
klare sehr beliebte grüne propaganda die
auch viele anderen übernommen haben die
dass die flutkatastrophe die wir vor
wenigen wochen etwas lebt haben ein
ergebnis von klimawandels ist in der
wissenschaft höchst höchst hilft
umstritten und weit entfernt davon dass
man es ein fakt schnellen könnte sowie
annalena baerbock das gerade tut manche
sagen das klima manche sagen es ist
wetter was es ist wir wissen es nicht
was annalena baerbock behauptet ist ein
fakt sondern ihre persönliche meinung
als grüne kanzlerin über nicht kommen
können wir hätten hubschrauber schicken
können aber es hat nicht funktioniert
weil es keine gemeinsame zusammenarbeit
im katastrophenschutz mit der bundes
gegen de gibt und sie stehen hier und
sitzen hier
einige wochen danach und dieses ganze
thema wie wappnen wir uns zukünftig
gegen diese katastrophen spielte absolut
keine rolle da schützt unsere sicherheit
in zukunft nicht wir brauchen endlich
eine klimapolitik die auch vorsorge und
schutz aufgebaut ist und das bedeutet
auch ein bundesamt der
versicherungsschutz kassier
verantwortung übernimmt weil ja
verantwortungsvolle politik bedeutet
dass man aufgrund eines solchen tages
seine politik ändert wenn man sieht dass
seine politik in die sackgasse geführt
hat was denn sonst was denn sonst sollen
wir tun wenn wir erleben das extrem wird
ereignisse zu nehmen was denn sonst
sollen wir tun wenn die am hinterteil
südeuropa abnimmt das jetzt in new york
was man kann es nicht oft genug zu tun
das was annalena baerbock hier tut ist
ein tatsächlich zynisches spiel mit
menschen die alles verloren haben und
mit über 100 toten und flutgebiet grüße
toten und sind in keiner weise das
ergebnis von politik diese politik steht
derzeit nicht zur wahl diesen
zusammenhang so konkret herzustellen ist
genau das was die anderen vorwirft sie
macht sich das schicksal von menschen zu
ihrem eigenen wahlkampfplakat menschen
sind hier nicht gestorben gegen
klimapolitik sondern wegen hoch wegen
mangelndem hochwasserschutz ganz
entscheidender unterschied
sondern man hört dass von psychologinnen
und psychologen man hört dass von
erzieherinnen und erzieher dass kinder
sich sorgen machen darüber wie werde ich
eigentlich in zukunft in diesem land
leben was passiert eigentlich was
passiert eigentlich wenn meine kita
gerade wetters wurde frage hören
erzieherinnen und erzieher jetzt in
nordrhein westfalen und im rheinland das
mit den kindern empfinde ich jetzt
wirklich als den gipfel und besonders
profile dass kinder ihre erzieherin
fragen ich muss ehrlich sagen ich hätte
es gerne mal wieder die namen der
erzieherin auch in der letzten zeit hat
an der backe gerne geschichten ohne
namen erzählt das ist wirklich perfide
vor allem männern bedenklich sind kinder
in der krise gehen
halt diese ängste sind real ein kind das
2018 geboren ist ihr lebt nicht einmal
in ihrem leben ein jahrhundert
hochwasser sondern nach all den
prognosen die wir derzeit haben werden
diese hochwasser alle zehn jahre kommt
diese sturzfluten alle paar jahre kommen
und deswegen ist es jetzt zeit dass
politisch zu verändern und sie sagen
dank von der fdp und von der cdu das
soll mal der markt regelt vielleicht
haben sie heute die zeitung
aufgeschlagen in der sz wurde das noch
mal berechnet wenn das allein der markt
regeln soll dann kostet die tonne co2
2800 euro
das ist zutiefst sozial ungerecht und
die klimakrise die regel kein markt weil
dem markt sind menschen herzlich egal
es braucht eine politik es braucht eine
politik die sagt wir machen das jetzt es
braucht eine politik wie gesagt wir
machen das jetzt anstatt 17 jahre weiter
in der kohle drinzubleiben 17 jahre
weiter und entscheiden unterscheiden sie
sich zwischen 10 und spd an keiner
stelle und er scheut sie reden ja oft
von respekt aber wie respektvoll ist es
in die lausitz zu fahren und sagen ich
werde weiter für den kohleausstieg
2038 eintreten und ein paar tage später
dann bei den umweltverbänden zu sagen
2034 wäre eigentlich auch ganz in
ordnung das ist für mich kein respekt
sondern das zeugt davon dass es keinen
kurs in der klimapolitik gibt bei der
spd und bei ihnen wenn sie dieses land
anführen sollen
17 jahre weiter und sie haben ja sie
haben wir ein klimaschutzgesetz
beschlossen wo richtigerweise drinsteht
wenn ein sektor das nicht erreicht da
muss man schauen die das in einem
anderen sektor geregelt wird wenn sie 17
jahre lang weiter co2 aus kohle
verstromen wollen dann bedeutet das dass
das so viel co2 ist für alle gebäude
zusammen dann erklären sie mir den
mieterinnen und mieter dass die jetzt
die ganzen klima aufgaben übernehmen
wollen weil sie nicht den mut haben den
kohleausstieg auf 2.030 endlich
vorzuziehen
und das dramatische an der situation
eine wichtige anordnung noch einmal zum
thema strom die grünen wollen aus der
kohle aussteigen ja sind wir uns
vermutlich alle einig sind uns aber auch
alle eigentlich deutschland braucht
stroms der kann dann ja nur dass wir
auch keine atomkraftwerke mehr haben aus
erneuerbaren energien kommt und eine
sache muss man über grüne politik der
letzten jahre ganz klar sagen es gibt
kein einziges erneuerbare energien
projekt in ganz deutschland das dann
nicht von grünen bürgerrechtsgruppen
verhindert worden ist dass es keine
stromtrassen durch deutschland gibt die
erneuerbare energien im land verteilt
ist das ergebnis ausschließlich von
grünem aktivismus und grüner politik mit
den grünen wenn die so weitermachen wird
es in deutschland für die
stromversorgung einfach eng und dazu
liefert annalena baerbock keine antwort
auf seiner jahrestagung deutlich gemacht
die fehlende planungssicherheit weil es
keine richtungsentscheidung von der
großen koalition gegeben haben ist eines
unser größten probleme für den
zukunftsstandort deutschland und ich
zitiere mal herrn russwurm es reicht
nicht klimaneutralität per gesetz
vorzuschreiben die politik muss auch
dringend etwas dafür tun dass dieses
ziel auch erreicht werden kann und
politische entscheidungen treffen und
genau darum geht es jetzt nicht
klimaschutz auf der karte zu schreiben
sondern politische entscheidungen zu
treffen und das heißt zwei prozent der
landesfläche gefällt sagt nutzen das
bedeutet den kohleausstieg vorzuziehen
und ab 2030 nur noch die mission freie
autos zuzulassen und es bedeutet auch
eine solarpflicht auf jedes dach und
dass sie selbst diesen antrag hier im
deutschen bundestag nicht zugelassen
haben bzw der geschäftsordnung
weggewischt haben zeigt wenn die große
koalition wenn sie herr scholz oder sie
herrliche demnächst hier weiter regieren
wollen dann wird das mit den
klimaschutzzielen einfach nichts werde
und jetzt in einer situation wo die wo
die finanzielle situation eben nicht
mehr so gut dasteht wie in den letzten
jahren müssen wir klare prioritäten
setzen weil die frau bundeskanzlerin
haben von den gleichwertigen
lebensverhältnissen gesprochen ja das
steht in unserem grundgesetz dass es
eine der zentralen aufgaben aber wenn
wir mal genauer hinschauen in unserem
land dann erleben wir ein riesengroßes
problem das wir nehmen nicht nur in
ländlichen regionen kein internet haben
sondern in ganz ganz vielen bereichen
unseres landes bei der digitalisierung
dem zukunftsthema nicht erst seit heute
sondern in den letzten zehn jahren sind
wir bei den 20 größten industrienationen
auf dem drittletzten platz das ist ihre
regierungsbilanz von acht jahren großer
koalition in der digitalisierung
entschieden bereich es ist so dass
mittlerweile jede sechste an dem punkt
wir haben es hier bei bild live auch
schon während der rede der kanzlerin
angesprochen könnte annalena baerbock
nicht wichtiger liegen die
digitalisierung bilanz der regierung
merkel ist eine absolute römer wüste wir
haben es in der korona pannonia gemerkt
wir sind das in die industrie nationen
des faxgerätes was annalena baerbock
dort kritisiert kritisiert sie
vollkommen zu recht es gibt für kinder
in deutschland keine gleichen standards
bei zugang zur digitalisierung und
schnell daten was für bildung so
unendlich hilft durch ist sehr guter
punkte von annalena baerbock
milliarden euro in unserem land haben
und ich will das nicht ich möchte dass
man auch im ländlichen raum mobil
unterwegs ist ich möchte dass wir auch
an allen orten in unserem land
vernünftige schulen und ein internet
haben und deswegen braucht die
schuldenbremse eine erweiterung durch
eine investitions regeln und dass sie
sich der weiterhin auf finanzminister
gegenstelle zeigt dass der respekt vor
der zukunft offensichtlich nicht so groß
ist all diejenigen die wirklich mal
unterwegs sind im leben die ihr leben
doch was das bedeutet wenn wir nicht in
unsere daseinsvorsorge investieren
grundschülerinnen und grundschüler der
dritten vierten klassen noch nicht
schwimmen weil die schwimmbäder im
ländlichen raum zu machen eben kunst und
kultur alle haben gesagt ja irgendwie
dieses systemrelevant aber genau da
brauchen wir jedoch in der werbung ganz
klar wird ist ohne sie den starken
staaten sie der regularien zum beispiel
solaranlagen sneijder solaranlagen aber
auch hier wieder mit der schuldenbremse
gefährde die wirtschaft ein die sie geld
erwirtschaften kannst du so ein immer
regularien vom staat ich sehe hier züge
einer planwirtschaft unserer
gesellschaft investieren zeigt auch in
welche richtung sie sich in zukunft
entscheiden
und da hilft es
da hilft es auch wenig dass ihnen jetzt
herrscht ein feld das wir eine
kindergrundsicherung brauchen wir haben
das hier im deutschen bundestag immer
wieder in all den jahren diskutiert und
es war ihr ministerium im
familienausschuss was immer wieder
deutlich gesagt habe ach nee
kindergelderhöhung darüber reden wir mal
aber die frage von anhebung der
hartz-iv-regelsätze das gehen wie er
nicht an jede mutter die weiß wie es am
ende des monats von dem hartz 4
kinderregelsätzen als familie zu leben
die muss sich an so einem schönen
sommertag immer wieder überlegen eis ist
nicht drin schwimm markt ist nicht drin
die neuen fußballschuhe sind sie auch
nicht drin weil das was ihre kinder und
familienpolitik bisher war für jedes
kind in diesem land bedeutet dass man 1
euro 50 zu vermögen grad als mutter für
sein kind und das reicht vorne und
hinten nicht aus
und weil wir gerade bei steuern und
gerechtigkeit sind wer ausgerechnet
den kampf gegen steuerbetrug lieber
weiter mit fax und brief führen will
denn frage ich wirklich ernsthaft
welcher gesellschaft wollen sie
eigentlich schienen und dass sie sich
dass sie sich aus angst die täglich
schlagzeilen in einer großen zeitung
[Applaus]
da spielst anderen berbalk unsere
zeitung an die bild zeitung und die
schlagzeile steuer stasi das ist genau
das was annalena baerbock belassen sie
sich da nicht täuschen sie möchte den
ultimativ einfachen an schmerz
mechanismus hat sie als ihr nachbar 2
bleibt dass ihre putzfrau anständig
versteuert ist dagegen geht annalena
baerbock jetzt vor es geht dabei nicht
darum dass sie beim thema steuersünder
sich gegen die großen und wenden will
sondern was die grünen hier wollen ist
der ansatz mechanismus für jeden um den
nachbarn anschwärzen zu können die
politik zu machen im klimaschutz bei der
frage gerechtigkeit und vor allen dingen
auch mit blick auf den kampf gegen die
pandemie
wir stehen gerade wieder vor einem
corona herbst wir sehen dass die
infizierten zahlen massiv nach oben
steigen und die hospitalisierung 's
quote wir haben krankenschwestern
pflegern und ärzten gesagt das wird
nicht noch einmal passieren dass wir
hier klatschen und ihr tag und nacht
durcharbeiten müssen und was passiert
wird es müsste jetzt eine entscheidung
getroffen werden von dieser
bundesregierung von cdu und spd zu sagen
wir rauschen nicht nochmal in so ein
chor ohne herz rein und er bringt ja
üble propaganda hier von annalena
baerbock die hospitalisierung spot
steigen nicht dramatisch an das hat sich
dramatisch entkoppelt die
infektionskette und die hospitalisierung
skorte hier macht sie tatsächlich auch
sehr unappetitliche weise wahlkampf mit
der pandemie in dem sie vor einem
horrorszenario waren den menschen angst
macht sie will dass kinder keine angst
haben was macht sie stellte ihn im
bundestag macht den menschen angst dass
es unappetitlicher corona wahlkampf der
mit fakten gar nichts zu tun
und den schülerinnen und schüler zweimal
die woche getestet werden warum soll das
nicht auch am arbeitsplatz möglich sein
diese debatte hatten wir schon mal in
diesem hohen haus und nach anderthalb
jahren ist es an der zeit dass das
endlich umgesetzt wird
und dann haben sie eigentlich
gesagt sie wollten jetzt in drei stunden
über afghanistan und eine
verantwortungsvolle außenpolitik
diskutieren das war ihr argument von cdu
und spd warum sind sie dem top per
geschäftsordnung afghanistan hier nicht
zugelassen haben und dann ist es doch
ein ganz schön hohe stück das sie sich
dann hier hinstellen auch sie herr
scholz und nichts zu diesem thema sagen
nichts dazu sagen was in den letzten
wochen eigentlich hinter bundes
erschienen ist und seit der seit der
letzten afghanistan debatte sind wir
noch neue dinge an das licht der
öffentlichkeit gekommen dass sie die
listen von dem wir hier vor wochen
gesprochen haben gar nicht weitergegeben
haben dass menschen vor dem flughafen
standen angerufen worden sind und dann
standen sie aber nicht auf der liste
drauf und durchzukommen stattdessen
wurde diese listen mit namen von
menschen die in lebensgefahr schweben
irgendwie an die taliban gegeben und
dass sie darüber hier und heute nicht
reden wollen das ist einfach unfair
antwort
ja auch taten annalena baerbock ein
punkt geht welche bei bild live schon
angesprochen haben wie olaf scholz und
wie angela merkel sich um das
unangenehme thema afghanistan
herumgedrückt und herumlavieren haben
das war tatsächlich nahezu unanständig
und es wird ist in diesem wahlkampf
eigentlich unwürdig annalena baerbock
spricht hat das größte versagen aus dem
politischen versagen der merkel
regierung vollkommen zu recht
nicht nur eine unverantwortliche
außenpolitik sondern das zeigt auch dass
man kein respekt vor diesem wohnhaus
hier hat und dass die
verteidigungsministerien jetzt alleine
ein löschungsanspruch in ihrem haus
durch setzt sie aber nicht bereit sind
das hier im deutschen bundestag zu
beschließen das ist wirklich ein unding
und ja sie können das per
geschäftsordnung hier von der
tagesordnung holen aber sie für ihre
verantwortung beim afghanistan debakel
nicht einfach wegwischen in der nächsten
legislatur wird es ein
untersuchungsausschuss dazu geben und
zwar nicht nur nicht viel zu arbeiten
sondern weil deutschland endlich wieder
eine aktive deutsche außenpolitik
braucht dieses wegducken in der
afghanistan politik ist doch ein spiegel
dessen was passiert ist in den letzten
acht jahren in europa deutschland ist
das stärkste land in der europäischen
union deutschland ist das land was immer
wieder sagt wir wollen europa eigentlich
weiter bauen auf ihren eigenen
koalitionsvertrag jetzt haben sie
irgendwie vergessen offensichtlich in
den letzten vier jahren stand als
obertitel drauf ein neuer aufbruch für
europa und was ist dann passiert
als er gesagt hat wir müssen jetzt mal
den globalen kampf gegen steuerbetrug
wirklich angehen mit blick auf eine
digital steuer haben sie gesagt er stolz
lassen wir das lieber mal sein geld sind
sie nach getrödelt mit reichlich
verspätung und die franzosen haben das
erst mal alleine gemacht als eine eu
kommissionspräsident in von der union
gesagt hat europa soll der erste
klimaneutrale kontinent sein fällt
nichts besseres ein weiter in brüssel
dafür zu lobbyieren das aber mit blick
auf die auto grenzwerte bitte mal nicht
so schnell gemacht wird und jetzt macht
das halt daimler alleine die stellen ab
2025 nur noch die autos her und es und
das unter tel
das heftigste ist passiert und ich komme
zum schluss der präsidentin der
europäischen flüchtlingspolitik
humanität und ordnung sind die pfeiler
unserer gemeinsamen werte union und was
haben sie vier jahre lang gemacht sich
in der viktor orban versteckt und gesagt
so lange der sich nicht bewegt bewegen
wir uns auch nicht europa wurde immer
gebaut dass einige sich zusammengetan
haben beim euro bei schenk bei der ost
erweiterung und genau dieser moment den
brauchen wir jetzt wieder in deutschland
was europapolitisch führt und sich nicht
hinter viktor orban versteckt
[Applaus]
etwas bizarrer punkt wäre wolfgang
schäuble annalena baerbock zu ordnen ist
wo die muss ich jetzt hinter wolfgang
hinter viktor orban versteckt hatte ist
für mich tatsächlich schwer zu erkennen
und wenn annalena baerbock sagt bei
migration dann ist der grüne wunsch
ordnung da muss man sagen das hat mit
dem wunsch vieler ihrer parteigenossen
nichts zu tun denn sie wollen so viel
ungeordnete migration wie menschen auf
der welt das eben für sich selber
wünschen
[Applaus]
[Musik]